[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos durante los últimos
tiempos hemos publicado un montón de
vídeos sobre venezuela y la terrible
situación política que este país
atraviesa os hemos contado cómo se ha
llegado hasta aquí cuáles son las
características básicas de esta narco
dictadura y que ha supuesto una
revolución la revolución bolivariana que
ha condenado a la pobreza a la mayor
parte de los venezolanos y que incluso
está provocando uno de los mayores
éxodos de toda la historia los
refugiados venezolanos ahora suman 34
millones implicaciones humanitarias
masivas advierte la onu sin embargo
mientras los acontecimientos se
precipitan a una velocidad de vértigo
con este hombre con juan guaidó
liderando una firme oposición al régimen
de maduro hemos pensado que nos faltaba
hacer un repaso general a una cuestión
fundamental
quienes son los principales aliados de
nicolás maduro quien es y porque a pesar
de todos siguen apoyando a este régimen
qué intereses tienen y cuyos efectos
amigos puede parecer increíble dadas las
circunstancias pero el régimen chavista
sigue teniendo importantes aliados
atentos porque estos son los cuatro
socios más grandes los cuatro mayores
aliados que sigue teniendo el sátrapa
venezolano
hoy por ti mañana por mí en 2010 comenzó
una bonita amistad o mejor dicho una
terrible amistad ese año nicolás maduro
viajó a turquía como canciller de
venezuela allí conoció al presidente
turco tayyip erdogán son dos políticos
que se sienten atacados por occidente y
la base de la relación es sobre todo
emocional
erdogán no olvida que maduro fue uno de
los primeros líderes que le apoyó
durante el intento de golpe de estado
del 15 de julio del 2016 ahora turquía
está devolviendo el apoyo recibido vamos
para que nos entendamos que es una
relación basada en algo así como oye
mira que resulta que el resto del mundo
nos ha puesto en la diana
ya ves solo porque dicen que somos
autoritarios como si fuera algo malo por
el orden ya ves tú que no respetamos la
libertad de prensa dicen en fin que si
te parece puesto me apoyas yo te apoyo
estos líderes populistas y autoritarios
están tratando de desarrollar relaciones
de hombre a hombre en lugar de confiar
en instituciones burocracias o reglas el
caso amigos es que desde que este
el golpe de estado turco o según se
sospecha el auto golpe de estado el
comercio entre ambos países se ha
multiplicado por 13 tan sólo en 2018 las
exportaciones de venezuela a turquía
superaron los 1.000 millones de dólares
y no no penséis que se trata de
productos industriales o incluso
agrícolas para nada fundamentalmente se
trata de la última fuente de divisas con
las que el régimen venezolano trata de
ganar oxígeno estoy hablando del oro mil
cuatrocientos ochenta toneladas de oro
especulador yo y es que veréis turquía
se ha convertido en algo así como el
centro de refinado certificación y
distribución del oro venezolano por así
decirlo el centro de lavado perfecto
para que el gobierno de nicolás maduro
pueda seguir obteniendo divisas algo que
es cada vez más complicado especialmente
tras el colapso que está sufriendo la
industria petrolera
[Música]
injertos socialistas es la estrategia
del injerto
las exportaciones de petróleo de
venezuela cayeron a un mínimo de 28 años
[Música]
según parece el acuerdo firmado entre
venezuela y turquía le estaría
permitiendo a caracas evadir las
sanciones de los eeuu misteriosa firma
turca ayudó a maduro a mover 900
millones de dólares en oro durante los
últimos meses ha sido frecuente ver en
el aeropuerto de caracas jets privados
procedentes de rusia y turquía algunos
de ellos por cierto propiedad de giner
una empresa minera muy cercana al
presidente
erdogán pues bien lo que se sospecha es
que estos aviones están llegando a
caracas para sacar oro del país de una
forma bastante opaca vamos que ya sabéis
dónde va a ir a parar buena parte de
este oro
[Aplausos]
aprovechándose de los cargos
pero las relaciones aún van más allá en
diciembre de 2018 como quien dice antes
de ayer
erdogán protagonizó la primera visita de
un jefe de estado turco a venezuela
durante ese viaje se firmaron acuerdos
comerciales por más de 5 mil millones de
dólares y se anunció la creación de
empresas conjuntas para la exploración y
explotación de carbón oro y petróleo
por ejemplo es muy significativo que la
industria alimentaria turca sea la
proveedora de cerca del 70% de los
alimentos repartidos por el gobierno de
venezuela bajo el programa clap 3 se
imaginan que sería de venezuela sin los
clap
pero sigamos con esto
[Música]
qué hay de lo mío es algo bien conocido
a lo largo de toda la revolución
bolivariana el papel de cuba ha sido
trascendental
[Aplausos]
[Música]
su baile ha suministrado primero a hugo
chávez y luego a nicolás maduró
paramilitares protección equipos de
inteligencia prácticamente todo lo que
los gerifaltes venezolanos han
necesitado para consolidar su poder
venezuela es nueve veces más grande que
cuba tiene el triple de población y su
economía es cuatro veces mayor el país
alberga las principales reservas de
petróleo del mundo sin embargo algunas
funciones cruciales del estado
venezolano han sido delegadas a
funcionarios cubanos o son directamente
controladas por la habana
puede ser polémico decirlo pero seamos
claros cuba se ha convertido en algo así
como un supermercado del terror para los
dictadores de aquí y de allá según el
secretario general de la organización de
estados américanos luis almagro el
número de cubanos presentes en venezuela
se situaría entre las 21.000 y las 46
mil personas
rubió agentes de cuba' dirigen
represiones en ureña venezuela-cuba es
responsable de represión y tortura en
venezuela- luis almagro secretario
general de la organización de estados
américanos por supuesto todo esto no ha
sido gratis
[Música]
a cambio de suministrar médicos y
paramilitares cuba ha recibido durante
los últimos años un montón de petróleo
en condiciones más que ventajosas del
gobierno venezolano de hecho aunque no
tan importantes como lo fueron sus
relaciones con la unión soviética
durante la revolución bolivariana la
economía cubana ha sido muy pero que muy
dependiente de venezuela
[Música]
sin embargo amigos tal y como están
marchando las cosas aunque hoy por hoy
todavía parecen estar jugando un papel
clave en la represión la isla no tiene
ni de lejos los recursos económicos para
mantener en pie al narco régimen
chavista vamos que es posible que en el
futuro su mayor papel sea el de dar
refugio a nicolás maduro y sus
compinches si es que la dea no los
capturó antes
empezamos a construir alianzas
integrales
los negocios son los negocios
si se dice habitualmente visual político
lo sabéis le hemos prestado mucha
atención a las relaciones entre caracas
y pekín y no no penséis que es una
cuestión ideológica fue es y
probablemente será con maduro es
inmaduro una cuestión de negocios el
petróleo es la razón más fundamental por
la que china y venezuela se unieron
china necesitaba mucho petróleo y
venezuela lo tenía la relación floreció
desde entonces y ambos construyeron unos
lazos basados en acuerdos de
financiación por petróleo veréis los
primeros acuerdos de préstamos por
petróleo entre china y venezuela datan
del año 2007 100 escuelas se ha
consolidado ya esta altura como
el país donde china tiene el más alto
a nivel de inversión en américa latina
para la venezuela de hugo chávez estos
acuerdos significaron dinero fresco
contante y sonante para su revolución
para china en cambio conseguir acceder a
los enormes recursos energéticos del
país latinoamericano era algo que la
economía china necesitaba a toda costa
sus tasas de consumo de petróleo crecían
un montón año tras año y necesitaban
lograr la seguridad del suministro
[Música]
y ojo porque no estamos hablando de poco
dinero
según los datos del centro de estudios
interamericano y la universidad de
boston entre el año 2007 y el año 2018
china le prestó al país latinoamericano
casi 70 mil millones de dólares a día de
hoy la deuda parece superar los 20 mil
millones y para ser justos hay que decir
que maduro no ha sido precisamente un
buen pagador y los esquemas de
financiamiento que tenemos con china nos
generan deuda debes saber venezuela en
pekín confiaban que con todo el dinero
que habían puesto sobre la mesa las
autoridades venezolanas conseguirían
hacer algo productivo al menos invertir
lo suficiente como para mantener el
nivel de producción de petróleo en pekín
jamás imaginaron que el gobierno de
venezuela pudiera ser tan desastroso y
como para los chinos todo es
fundamentalmente una cuestión de
negocios pues hemos visto cosas como
esta
china demanda a la compañía petrolera de
venezuela por facturas impagadas
[Música]
a pesar de todo en pekín sospechan que
si se produce un cambio de gobierno sus
acuerdos podrían correr peligro lo que
podría suponer no cobrar parte de la
deuda que venezuela tiene que pagar en
petróleo o incluso perder el acceso
privilegiado que están consiguiendo a
las enormes reservas venezolanas
precisamente por este motivo uno de los
objetivos que parece estar persiguiendo
el presidente juan guaidó es convencer a
los chinos de que pase lo que pase los
acuerdos se van a respetar china habla
con la oposición de venezuela para
proteger sus inversiones
no importa cómo evolucione la situación
la cooperación entre china y venezuela
no debe ser socavada en cualquier caso
amigo si queréis saber más sobre esta
relación no os perdáis este vídeo y por
último la que tal vez sea la última
esperanza de nicolás maduro
[Música]
una punta de lanza contra occidente a
día de hoy la rusia de vladimir putin es
el mayor respaldo internacional con el
que cuenta el régimen de nicolás maduro
[Música]
durante las últimas dos décadas las
empresas rusas han logrado importantes
contratos militares y desde 2015 además
muchos derechos sobre algunos de los
campos de petróleo y gas más importantes
de venezuela todo lo han conseguido a
precio de saldo queréis un ejemplo
fijaos
[Música]
a cambio de un desesperado rescate de
1500 millones de dólares el gobierno
venezolano ha llegado a establecer como
garantía el 49 9% de su participación en
5 la joya de la corona de pedevesa una
petrolera con actividad en eeuu donde es
dueña de tres refinerías una enorme red
de gasoductos y casi 6.000 estaciones de
servicio si perder esa no paga dos mil
quinientos millones de dólares de deudas
contraídas con rosneft gazprom venezuela
podría verse obligada a liquidar a
precio de saldo el que a día de hoy es
su activo industrial más valioso todo
por apenas 1.500 millones de dólares
[Música]
un momento 1500 millones por la mitad de
citgo que vale muchísimo más estamos de
guasa bienvenidos a las rebajas de
maduro
[Música]
que tras las últimas sanciones de eeuu
todo esto puede haber quedado en nada
entre otras cosas porque no parece que
este tipo de acuerdos vayan a ser
reconocidos por un gobierno de eeuu
quien no reconoce como presidente a
nicolás maduro
pero a cero
el caso amigos es que rusia se ha
convertido en el proveedor número uno de
armas equipos militares e instrumentos
de represión para el gobierno venezolano
[Música]
misiles tanques aviones el gobierno
bolivariano se ha gastado un dineral
durante los últimos años en equipos
rusos
para putin venezuela ha significado un
enorme negocio para la industria militar
que tan importante es en rusia pero
ahora también lo ve como una oportunidad
para seguir metiendo el dedo en el ojo a
occidente al tiempo que incrementa su
control sobre algunas de las mayores
reservas energéticas del planeta
[Música]
en fin amigos estos son los cuatro
aliados más importantes con los que aún
cuenta la narcodictadura de nicolás
maduró junto a ellos están también
países como bolivia nicaragua o
bielorrusia pero con una influencia en
el mundo muy pequeña a la hora de la
verdad el gobierno bolivariano va a
hacer lo posible para ganarse un apoyo
total expreso y firme de rusia china y
turquía el de cuba ya lo tiene aunque
para ello tenga que vender lo poco que
aun queda de la mismísima venezuela sin
embargo la debilidad política y el caos
creado por el gobierno chavista es tan
grande que esto puede que ya no sea
suficiente en fin con este vídeo hemos
querido situar os mejor sobre quienes
siguen siendo los principales valedores
de todo este inmenso desastre pero ahora
turno para ti y ojo que hoy os dejamos
una pregunta muy pero que muy importante
crees que maduró conseguirá mantenerse
en el poder al menos por lo que queda de
2019 déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si te ha resultado interesante este
vídeo darle al botón de like y no
olvides suscribirte
avisa al político un saludo y hasta la
próxima especulador
[Aplausos]
y qué
[Música]